>> John Fenn: Good afternoon.
We're going to get started here.
Thanks for your patience.
I'm John Fenn, the head
of research and programs
at the American Folklife Center
here at the Library of Congress.
And I'd like to welcome you
on behalf of all the staff
to the latest presentation
in our ongoing Benjamin
A. Botkin lecture series.
The Botkin series allows
us to highlight the work
of leading scholars in the
discipline of folklore,
ethnomusicology, oral
history, and cultural heritage,
while enhancing our collections.
For the center and the library,
the Botkin lectures
form an important facet
of acquisition activities.
Each lecture is video
recorded and becomes part
of our permanent collection.
In addition, the lectures
are later posted as webcasts
in the library's website where
they are available for viewing
to internet patrons
throughout the world.
So, now would be
an excellent time
to turn off your electronic
devices, and or put them
in airplane mode, lest you
become part of the recording.
Today I have the honor
of introducing the distinguished
folklorist, Billy Jean Ancelet,
a professor emeritus
at the University
of Louisiana at Lafayette.
Over the years, we have
presented many eminent
colleagues, but few of them have
made a significant an impact
on the documentation, public
awareness, and revitalization
of their chosen areas
of interest
as has Professor Ancelet.
Even fewer of them have
been officially knighted
by the Government of France
for their efforts [gasps].
Dr. Ancelet was born in Church
Point, Louisiana and grew
up in the epicenter of
Cajun and Creole culture.
He French as an undergraduate
at what was then University
of Southwestern Louisiana, later
to be renamed the University
of Louisiana Lafayette, and
received a Master's in folklore
from Indiana University.
At IU he taught for a few years
before moving on to a doctorate
in Etudes Creoles,
anthropology and linguistics,
from the Universite de
Provence in Marseille in 1984.
Professor Ancelet's
life-long commitment
to Louisiana culture has
served as a touchstone
for his many landmark
contributions as a scholar
and a culture activist, both
inside and outside the academy.
He cofounded the Tribute
to Cajun Music in 1974,
which developed into the
annual Festivals Acadiens.
And for more than a decade
hosted the Rendez-vous des
Cajuns, an influential weekly
music radio program on KRVS.
He has authored an impressive
number of books and articles,
has been involved in
a number of recordings
and documentary films, and,
as an educator, has trained
and guided a generation of
scholars specializing in Cajun,
Creole, and Franco-American
culture.
Ancelet has served as
chair of the University
of Louisiana Modern
Languages Department,
as well as the founding
director of its renowned Center
for Acadian and Creole Folklore.
His many other awards and honors
include being named the Willis
Granger and Tom Debaillon
Professor of Francophone Studies
in 2005 and being
made a Chevalier
in l Ordre des Arts et des
Lettres de la Republique
Francaise in 2006 by
the Governor of France
for important contributions
to French art and literature.
In 2008 he was awarded the
prestigious Americo Paredes
Prize by the American
Folklore Socient.
And, in 2009, he was named
Louisiana Humanist of the Year
by the Louisiana Endowment
for the Humanities.
I would go on, but I think I've
given you a sense of why we are
so delighted to have Dr.
Ancelet here today with us.
Please join me in welcoming
him for his talk on the theory
and practice of folklore in
Cajun and Creole Louisiana.
[ Applause ]
>> Billy Jean Ancelet:
Thank you.
It kind of made me
tired hearing all that.
The first part of this
talk deals with how I got
into the study and
practice of folklore.
The second deals with
what I learned and tried
to do after that happened.
I will ramble.
The story is pretty wild and
woolly, but I had a blast
and I got paid to do much of it.
I grew up in Cajun -- in a
Cajun French-speaking family
in south Louisiana.
As a child, I spent a lot
of time with the family
of my father's sister
in Vatican, Louisiana.
They took care of me
while my parents worked.
Only one person in the house
spoke a little English,
so I grew up speaking French.
When I was in the eighth
grade, I found myself
in an academic French
class for the first time.
In it, French was taught
as though it were
a foreign language.
In in the summer of 1967 I spent
six weeks in a study program
in Switzerland and France.
When I returned, I
called my aunt in Vatican
to tell her about my trip.
I was talking a mile a minute
about [speaking foreign
language] using the grammar
and vocabulary I
had learned aboard.
My aunt interrupted me saying,
[speaking foreign language]
in perfect Cajun French.
Baby, baby, it seems
like I can't understand
a word you're saying.
I immediately understood
that I was imitating an
imported style of French.
That was my first epiphany
concerning the value
of the vernacular.
Fast-forward to 1974,
I was in Mamou,
Louisiana once again trying
to track down Hugh Reed,
who you see here with the
black eye, to try to get him
to tell me some more
of the fascinating,
tall tales that would eventually
make up a significant part
of my dissertation, and would
be the subject of several
of the conference
papers, articles,
and books that would
eventually contribute
to my tenure and promotions.
I asked a waitress in the
Travelers Cafe if she knew
where I might find him.
She shot back with a curious
grin, you're looking for him?
When I see him coming,
I hide in the kitchen.
I don't want to hear
all that nonsense.
Not long after, I found myself
in a graduate French course
at Indiana University
on the literature
of [speaking foreign language].
We were considering [speaking
foreign language] from the end
of the 17th century, in which
his character tries to get
to the moon by filling hundreds
of bottles with dew and rising
with them in the morning.
The little people he dreams of
meeting eventually make comments
about life in his country
of origin and their --
from their unique perspective.
I raised my hand and pointed
out that I had collected
remarkably similar oral stories
from Hugh Reed [assumed
spelling] and his brothers,
Irving [assumed spelling]
and Revon,
in one of which Jim
Israel goes to the moon
in a runaway hay
baler by accident
and meets little green men
there who comment on life
in the storyteller's
native Mamou.
I was fascinated by the apparent
resilience of this tradition
and narrative strategy
among people who after --
who were, after all
the descendants
of the French settlers who left
France in the same 17th-century
to come to America --
North America, and
eventually to Louisiana.
My professor did not
understand why I would bring
up such an unrelated issue in
her class on French literature.
I realized I might be
in the wrong place.
By then, my highly improvised
early research on Cajun
and Creole music, folktales, and
language had made me understand
that my study of French
was driven by my interest
in understanding the Frenchness
[phonetic] of Louisiana.
I decided that I would drop
the class, do my best to finish
out the semester, and go back
home to rethink my plans.
But I had a card in my
pocket from Ralph Rentschler,
the director of the Smithsonian
Institution's folklife program,
who had assisted us in preparing
and presenting the first tribute
to Cajun music concert
in March of 1974.
There he is between
two ballad singers.
When I had mentioned
to him that I was going
to Indiana University, he gave
me his card with a message on it
and said that I should say hello
to his friend, Henry Glassie,
at IU's Folklore Institute.
Out of a sense of
obligation after that incident
in the French class, I
dropped in to the institute
and asked the receptionist,
[inaudible],
if there was someone
named Henry Glassie there.
I didn't know that Professor
Glassie was an internationally
renowned folklorist.
It would've been
kind like, you know,
going to the College
de France and saying,
is there some guy named Claude
Levi-Strauss here [laughter]?
She gasped, pointed
behind her to his office,
and said, yeah, he's in there.
I heard Glassie chuckle
and say, who is that?
I said, I'm Barry
Ancelet from Louisiana.
He said, come on in.
I introduced myself, handing him
Rentschler's card, and he said,
oh, you're from Louisiana.
Do you know Dewey Balfa?
I nearly screamed, yes, I did.
And then I told him
what had just happened.
He said, well, maybe this
is where you need to be.
I transferred to the
folklore program and was able
to preserve my ties
with the French program
through other professors there,
including linguist
Albert Valdman
and Africanist Emile
Snyder, who understood
and encouraged my
particular interests.
Why folklore?
I didn't even know there was
such an academic discipline
until I arrived at
Indiana University in 1974.
Soon enough, I found
myself taking classes
from Richard Dorson, Linda
Dague, Mary Ellen Brown,
Bruce Rose, a literal who's
who in American folklore.
I didn't know who
any of them were.
I found out.
But I had already
come to understand,
through my experiences
in Louisiana, that the --
that the language
was inseparable
from the culture
that it expressed.
Another thing that was
obvious was that very little
of this could be found
on library shelves.
Ultimately, getting at
Louisiana's French heritage
and culture would require
-- would require --
An improvised hybrid
approach involving real people
in real time.
That approach turned
out to be folklore.
And I must say, also, that
some of this had to do
with the counterculture
movement.
This was, after all, you know,
the late '60s, early '70s.
And, you know, we were
interested in protesting.
Are we good?
We were interested
in protesting.
And, for us, the
counterculture was protesting
against Americanization, and
it involved revitalization
of Louisiana French
language and culture.
No accident that the Council
for the Development of French
in Louisiana was
founded in 1968,
1968 when so many
other things happened.
The study of culture,
literature, and language
through the lens of folklore
has been the foundation
for my entire career, which
I admit I have improvised all
along the way.
I left in the Indiana University
with a master's degree
in folklore, and eventually
continued my graduate studies
at Aix-en-Provence where
I received a doctorate
in Creole studies,
combining anthropology
and linguistics working
with Robert Sonoseau
[assumed spelling]
and Jean-Claude Bouvier [assumed
spelling], who were reinventing
and reinvigorating the
study of orality in France.
My thesis included that story
about the accidental voyage
to the moon, among many others
that I collected
throughout south Louisiana.
I guess that it was fitting
because my theoretical approach
to just about everything I have
ever studied has been based
on the rich and fecund
principles of storytelling,
including improvisation,
vernacular creation,
and carnivalesque humor.
I also dedicated my
first ever article,
published as a folklorist,
to the waitress
in the Travelers
Cafe [laughter],
who never understood what a
supposedly serious college
student was doing looking
for somebody she tried
to get away from every day.
I've often found myself
exploring issues whose academic
value has not been
immediately evident.
Much of my research is
based on fieldwork in bars,
in barbershops, and dance halls
and back porches
and Mardi Gras runs.
Can you find me?
[ Inaudible ]
Am I there?
No. I will appear to you.
There I am [laughter].
From that perspective,
you really understand
the Mardi Gras.
[ Inaudible ]
Oh, I'll leave that
to you to find.
It's Mardi Gras after all.
As per the old saw, it
has not always been easy,
but somebody had to do it.
My research has resulted in
the usual articles and books,
but also in documentary films,
television, and radio programs,
festivals, museum and
photographic exhibitions,
album liner notes, public
lectures, literary readings,
teacher training seminars,
reports to state and
federal agencies.
I'm grateful and fortunate that
my colleagues and administrators
at the University of Louisiana
at Lafayette have
been flexible enough
to recognize the
value of what I do.
I've had a remarkably
collaborative career
by the honor of good fortune
to work with generous,
inspiring colleagues,
including editors, filmmakers,
sound engineers, production
crews, fellow teachers,
folklorists, historians,
linguists, poets, playwrights,
screenplay writers,
photographers, journalists,
a few politicians,
lawyers, and even a chef.
They've all provided me with
the countless opportunities
for collaboration and
years of inspiration
and dedication to
our common causes.
They all taught me how to
read and write and look
and listen and wonder.
I owe a debt -- a debt
of gratitude, as well,
to the singers and storytellers
and Mardi Gras runners
and dancers, including my
family and community of friends,
who have always so generously
shared what they know and do
with me, most of them
[speaking foreign language],
learn much of what
I have come to know
from vernacular professors, such
as Dewey Balfa and Ben Guine
and Clifton Chenier and
Canray Fontenot, [inaudible],
Hugh and Irvine Reed,
among many others.
I've been honored to work
with them and learn from them,
and I've come to love
them all as friends.
I've had the honor of
eulogizing many of them
when they passed away.
It was never only the songs
and the stories and the crafts,
it was the coffee and
camaraderie, the bull sessions
and the jam sessions and the
fishing trips and the serious
and casual conversations
about almost everything
and nothing in particular.
The rest of this talk focuses on
the relationship between theory
and the practice of folklore
between what folklorists think
and how they convey the results
of that thought to a range
of audiences from
other colleagues
to the general public.
First, a word about
theory and practice.
Some folklorists have seen
a dichotomy between the two.
I have always seen them as
inextricably integrated.
I'm typically more interested
in discussing the practice
than the theory, but
both are always in play.
I came to understand,
for myself,
what Regina Bendix
eventually theorized in her --
in search of authenticity
in countless conversations
with musicians and storytellers
and the makers of things
about the [inaudible], as well
as what Elaine Lawless
eventually called reciprocal
fieldwork by negotiating
meaningful
and productive relationships
with countless,
generous collaborators,
whom I learned early
on were much more
than just informants.
In my transcriptions of the
recorded interviews I made
with them, I still cannot bring
myself to identify them as L1
and L0 as linguistic
practice recommends.
The most -- for example,
the most I will reduce
Eva Boudreaux,
with whom I shared
storytelling sessions
and watched shoot squirrels
out of her back door, is EB.
I came to understand
what an implement --
and there she is
shooting squirrels
in the backyard [laughter].
I came to understand and
implement issues that scholars,
such as Walter Ong,
Paul Zumthor,
Pierre Borgia [assumed
spelling],
and Bruce Jackson
articulated concerning orality
and the challenge
of interpreting
and representing stories
in written form by trudging
through an evolution
of strategies
to resolve these
issues for my own --
for my use in my own work.
I came to improvise takeoffs
on what Clifford
Geertz called deep play,
and what Mikhail Batin
[assumed spelling]
and Victor Turner called the
carnivalesque laughter while
lying face down in the middle
of the [inaudible] Mardi
Gras circle dressed
as a pregnant woman waiting
to be ritually flogged
and then giving birth to a
bottle of whiskey [laughter].
From that perspective,
you learn a lot.
You understand a lot
about Mardi Gras.
I came to understand the
importance of performance
and contextual considerations
described by scholars
such as Roger Abrahams, Kenny
Goldstein, and Nick Spitzer
by thinking through the very
real and evolving performance
and contextual issues
involved in documenting
and presenting folk performers
and putting those into practice
in festivals and
concerts, museum exhibitions
and documentary films,
in radio programs
and community presentations --
In what I have come to
call guerrilla academics,
sneaking education to people
while they think they're
being entertained.
For me, theories are
not ends in themselves.
They are, instead, the tools and
blueprints I need to understand
and present what I am studying.
By any means necessary, to
borrow from Jean-Paul Sartre
and Malcolm X, I have imported
some, improvised variance
of others, and then I use them.
For me, the pursuit
of the universal always
began with the local.
The universe, after all, is made
up of an infinity of localities.
The practice of folklore
generally starts with fieldwork,
the process of gathering
information
from cultural sources.
For me, it was the only way
to reach the information
that was otherwise
missing from the record.
The most important, untapped
source for the information
on Cajuns and Creoles are
Cajuns and Creoles themselves.
The fieldwork-based approach
of folkloristics provides a
method to reach that source.
The naturally interdisciplinary
nature
of folkloristics necessarily
integrating considerations
of history and art, text and
context provides the wide range
of approaches that necessary
to understand the complexities
of culture and tradition,
including oral tradition,
traditional music, vernacular
architecture, folk art,
seasonal rituals, and
other cultural expressions.
Folkloristics also
leads to considerations
of important cultural and social
issues, such as conservation,
transmission, and innovation
within the context of tradition.
And folkloristics
and linguistics make perfect
partners in the effort
to understand the context
of French Louisiana.
Now, getting back to earlier.
The reason I knew Dewey Balfa
when Henry Glassie asked is
another part of the story.
In 1972 I spent an academic
year in France, '72, '73.
Homesick after nearly
a year away
from my native south Louisiana,
I was drawn to an announcement
of Roger Mason performing
[speaking foreign language].
There's the countercultural
connection.
There, among many other songs,
I heard him playing
what I recognized
to be a simplified version
of the Crowley Two-Step.
[ Music ]
I heard that when I
was buying my ticket.
[ Music ]
And when I heard that, it
hit me like a ton of bricks.
I said, that's what I'm missing.
That's what's been missing here.
And, so, I rushed down and had
a wonderful evening with him.
After the concert, I met with
Mason, an American folk musician
who had encountered Cajun music
on the folk festival circuit,
and who was then
performing it in France.
I told him how much I
appreciated hearing --
he was an Army brat and
traveled all over the world.
I told him how much I
appreciated hearing the music
from home.
Growing up in the late 1950's
and '60s, I listened to rock
and roll like the
rest of my generation,
but we heard Cajun music on
the radio, on television,
and when it was daddy's
turn to choose the records.
Mason said, if you're
from Louisiana you must know
the people I learned from,
Dewey Balfa, Nathan Abshire.
I didn't know any of
them at that point.
They had not come up in any
of my classes back home.
Mason suggested if I was
interested in learning more,
I should look up Dewey Balfa
upon my return to Louisiana.
That's exactly what I did.
I want to Dewey Balfa's
house just south of Basile,
introduced myself, telling him
about the experience
I had in France.
I said, are you Dewey Balfa?
Yeah. Well, my name
is Barry Ancelet
and I [making sounds
with mouth].
I was talking like
an auctioneer.
He said, calm down,
son [laughter].
Come on in, said the spider
to the fly [laughter].
And the rest, as
they say, is history.
We started a conversation
that went on -- sorry.
That's him.
We started a conversation that
went on for nearly two decades.
I learned at least
as much from Dewey
as from any professor I ever had
in any formal academic setting.
People are most aware of my
work in Cajun and Creole music,
perhaps because of
the high visibility
of Festivals Acadiens et
Creoles, which I helped found
and still direct, and the weekly
Liberty Theater live radio show,
which I did for 24 years.
But what first drew me
to the study of Cajun
and Creole folk cultures
was oral tradition.
My first book, Cajun
and Creole Music Makers,
grew out of my work with
musicians, but it was based more
on their stories
than their music.
Elemore Morgan Junior
and I got the idea
to visit the musicians
involved in the first festival
to visit them where they
lived, worked, and played,
to interview them about
their lives and experiences,
and to photograph them
in their own worlds.
This is Vares Connor [assumed
spelling], well-known, or,
not so well-known fiddler.
Nathan Abshire on
his front porch.
What we were doing
was indeed fieldwork,
but it felt more like visiting.
It was our intention to see
and hear in their own terms,
as I wrote in the introduction,
these barbers and bus drivers
and farmers and firefighters
and mechanics and masons,
who sell discount furniture
and discount gas and insurance
and insulation work nine to
five and seven to seven, onshore
and offshore, and make
art out of everyday life,
because they were
becoming important figures
in this cultural
self-preservation experiment.
Elemore and I worked for
10 years on the project,
collecting oral histories
and taking photographs
of these remarkable
performers in various contexts,
from their kitchens and front
porches, to festival stages
and concert halls, in
Louisiana and far beyond.
Around the same time,
I became interested
in Louisiana French
fictional tales.
French-speaking Cajuns
and Creoles had virtually
no literary tradition
since most did not have
the opportunity to learn
to read or write French.
Yet, we did have a tradition
of oral poetry in songs
and oral stories in tales.
And just because
the storytellers
and singers could not themselves
write their own stories
and songs, this did not
mean that the stories
and songs could not be written
by someone who had learned
to write the language
of their expression.
In an attempt to place these
traditions and [inaudible]
that they represent
on the record,
I began recording folktales,
as well as folksongs
and transcribing them.
Lacking any formal
training in the beginning,
I improvised my own first
fieldwork forays based
on instinct and good intentions.
You know, that road
to hell [laughter]?
I found that identifying
potential singers was
fairly easy.
Friends and family members
were generally aware of those
in their midst who can sing.
Identifying storytellers proved
to be more of a challenge.
Everybody tells stories,
but who knows who does?
At least initially, when --
like some of my predecessors,
Alcee Fortier, Elizabeth
Brandon, Corinne Saucier.
I was using fieldwork techniques
designed to elicit the kind
of animal tales and magic tales
that clearly illustrate
the connection
between French Louisiana
and its historical
and cultural roots
in France and Africa.
I was confounded by
this curious difficulty
in finding those
kinds of stories,
found some, but it was hard.
And it began to occur to me
that something must be wrong.
Corinne Saucier had
written in the introduction
to her collection of 33
Louisiana French folktales
that her collection of
33 stories was small,
but representative of a culture
that was fast disappearing
in our mechanized age.
I thought, there's
something wrong with this,
because my admittedly activist
perspective made me unwilling
to admit that the tradition
was dying and, second,
I knew that there
were stories out there
because of the thousands
I had heard over the years
in my father's barbershop
where I spent many afternoons
after school and around barbecue
pits and in shipping boats --
in fishing boats and lots
of other places, in bars.
So, I rethought my fieldwork
strategy and I realized
that it was more
effective to look
for storytellers than stories.
That information
about carnivalesque humor was
more likely to come from folks
in a bar or a barbershop
or a garage
than from those running
City Hall
or local museums or churches.
An essential aspect of my change
in methodology involved
being open to any context
and form of storytelling.
I found people remembered
from long ago --
I found that my early method
had exposed the tradition
of memory stories that some
people remembered from long ago,
but no longer really
actively told.
While my new approach exposed
a more active tradition,
jokes and tall tales and
personal experience narratives
that people were telling
each other on their own,
unprompted by a folklorist
question.
I basically learned
to shut up and listen.
It became -- quickly
became clear
that stories were not
ends in themselves.
The storytellers themselves
were the real treasures.
My aim was to consider their
ability to adapt, innovate,
create new forms of stories
through their talent
and personality.
Their willingness to share
their knowledge was essential
to the progress of my research.
The first time I met Mrs.
Eva Boudreaux, for example,
she told me four stories, that's
the lady shooting the gun back
in -- she told me four stories,
including an animal tale
featuring [speaking foreign
language], a version of
[speaking foreign language],
the first from African origins,
the second from French origins,
responding to my
request for such tales.
By the time I visited
her one year later,
I had had my epiphany and
opened my consideration of tales
to include anything
she wanted to tell.
She told me seven more stories.
Some of them jokes,
personal experience stories.
When I returned home that
night, I found a message
that Mrs. Boudreaux had
called saying she wanted --
she had some more stories
she wanted to tell me.
I said, I know.
I went earlier today
to record her.
My mother said, no, no, she just
called and said she wants you
to go back tomorrow because
she's got some more she forgot
to tell you today.
I returned the next day and
she told me eight more stories.
Over the years, she dredged up
dozens and dozens and dozens
of stories from her
memory to tell me,
many of them while waiting for
the bass to bite in her pond.
Similarly, I first met Ben
Guine while tracking down leads
on storytellers the old way,
in Parks, Parks, Louisiana,
a place called Promised Land.
A little boy who had won
the foot race to my truck
when I asked a group of children
for help in finding where people
on my list lived,
eventually took me
to his grandfather's house.
He went with us to
the last house
and heard what we
were asking for and,
when we left disappointed
because the lady didn't tell
those kinds of stories, he said,
my grandfather tells
those stories.
So, we took -- went to
his grandfather's house
and there I met Ben Guine, who
quite literally left a plate
of steaming crawfish stew
on his kitchen table to come
into the living room to tell
us tales, literally preferring
to tell stories than eat.
Over the years he, too, told me
dozens of stories of all sorts.
His remarkable storytelling
talents and wide repertoire
of stories eventually attracted
considerable attention,
including a filming session by
Louisiana Public Broadcasting
on the porch of his little house
in Promised Land
along the Bayou Teche.
To the astonishment and eventual
delight of his neighbors,
who had stopped listening
to his stories years before,
but now LPB was there, and
a few weeks later he appears
on television and, so,
Ben gets reconsidered
in his own community.
Based on a philosophy of
cultural activism again,
I tried to find ways to
integrate people like this
into the ongoing effort
to preserve Louisiana's
French language and culture.
Mrs. Boudreaux, Ben Guine,
and several other storytellers
appeared in storytelling events
at festivals and
schools, thrilling crowds
and schoolchildren with
their impressive repertoires
and masterful styles.
Sometimes in addition to,
sometimes instead of documenting
and analyzing past performances
within the scholarly community,
some folklorists strive
to program and present one
of those next performances in a
setting that will communicate it
to a wider audience, not
on the page but on a stage.
This practice brings
challenges of its own.
For example, the most
sensitively programmed cultural
presentation at a folk
festival is not the same
as the natural performance
in its own time and place.
But some of these
concerns can be resolved,
or at least mitigated, with
the same sort of careful
and serious study of performance
and context as that produced
in the academic setting.
Programming issues
were directly related
to the activist fieldwork
and archival philosophies
at the heart of the University
of Louisiana Center for Acadian
and Creole Folklore,
now a part of the Center
for Louisiana Studies.
The theoretical issues
underpinning the fieldwork
that initially led to the
production of the first tribute
to Cajun Music Festival, March
26, 1974, as well as the issues
that emerged and evolved as the
concert became an annual event,
were directly related
to the establishment
of the center's archives.
The programming of the festival
was based on an integration
of ideas that grew out
of two distinct camps.
On the one hand, activist
folklife-based considerations
as influenced by the Smithsonian
Institution's Festival
of American Folklife
and, on the other,
linguistic-based considerations
that grew out of the Council
for the development of French
and Louisiana's language
and cultural preservation
initiatives.
Fieldwork and programming
practices evolved based
on a desire to discover
and present excellent
folk performers
from real life context, avoiding
more self-conscious public
purveyors of folkloric culture.
The fieldwork practices
that grew
out of the festival
experience also contributed
to the fieldwork practices
that address the collection
and analysis of other
traditional genres
in French Louisiana,
including oral tradition
and material culture.
Selecting the collection
of performers
who would essentially define
the moment in Cajun music
and zydeco each year
posed interesting problems
and opportunities for
festival producers,
including the incorporation
of young performers
and the new emerging styles
that are a necessary part
of any living tradition.
Dewey Balfa put it best.
He said, I'm interested in the
very life of this culture --
And how it continues to
evolve its own terms.
I don't want to freeze dry
it or pin it to the wall
like a dead butterfly.
Dewey was not only a musician,
but what folklorists have come
to call a community scholar.
That is, a member of a folk
community who has learned
to address the issues that
are at the heart of the study
and practice of folklore,
such as cultural equity
and the relationship between
preservation and innovation
within the traditional context.
Inspired by Dewey and
enriched by his connections
to the Smithsonian folklife
program staff, including,
especially, Ralph Rentschler,
who had first recorded him
in 1964 as a fieldworker for
the Newport Folk Festival,
we prepared the first tribute to
Cajun Music Festival together.
The fieldwork we did for the
festival was a natural extension
of the fieldwork that had
begun with John and Alan Lomax,
who collected folksongs in
Louisiana for the Library
of Congress in 1930
-- in the 1930's.
The Lomax's had a sort
of new deal style
activist agenda intending
for their collection
to serve as the basis
for cultural recycling projects
in regions throughout
the country.
Based on his experience in
French Louisiana in 1934,
and from his position on the
Newport Folk Festival board
in 1964, Alan sent Ralph
Rentschler and Mike Seeger
to Louisiana to identify
musicians who would be invited
to perform at Newport
later that year.
Following leads from Harry
Auster, who had collected
in the area a few years before,
they found Gladdie Thibodeaux,
Louis Venesse LeJeune,
and Dewey Balfa,
who served as a last-minute
replacement
on guitar, by the way.
Dewey noted that they initially
thought the crowd hated their
music because they
weren't dancing [laughter].
Then, at the end of that first
song, the crowd applauded.
It was an experience the dance
hall musicians had never had,
but also one they never forgot.
Dewey reported turning
to Venesse and saying,
what are they doing [laughter]?
He was overwhelmed
by this reception
for what was often
dismissed as nothing
but chanky-chank
[phonetic] back home.
Came back home to
Louisiana determined
to spread the good news,
that Cajun music was
appreciated outside the area.
He maintained close contact with
Rentschler, who became director
of folklife programs at
the Smithsonian in '68.
There, Rentschler went on to
produce the annual Festival
of American Folklife,
celebrating the country's
rich, cultural diversity.
These festivals often
featured Cajun and Creole music
that Rentschler had encountered
during his early fieldwork.
Through his steady
contact with Rentschler
and other folklorists,
Balfa learned to articulate
such issues as cultural
conservation
and the process of tradition.
The first Cajun music festival
was an overwhelming success,
surprising even the most
enthusiastic of his organizers.
Musicians were selected
according to the --
to notions of cultural
authenticity established
by Rentschler and Balfa.
No crooners, Rentschler
cautioned.
His preference for the high,
clear, the high-pitched vocals
and unadorned instrumental
styles
of early Cajun music
dominated the evening.
The concert was structured
to feature the historical
development of Cajun
and Creole music, ballad
singers, Inez Catalan
and Marcus Landry, twin fiddlers
Dennis McGee and Sady Courville,
early stylists, Mark
Savoir [assumed spelling],
Lionel Leleux, and Vares
Connor, Nathan Abshire,
the Balfa brothers, the Ardwin
[assumed spelling] family,
as well as more modern
sounds of Clifton Chenier,
[inaudible], and the Cajun Aces.
Cajun country star, Jimmy
Newman, originally from Mamou,
but then living in Nashville,
whose hit Lache Pas La Patate,
was in full swing, was used
to anchor the concert despite
his sophisticated instrumental
arrangements and silky vocals.
Even Rentschler saw the wisdom
of Dewey's brilliant plan
to use Newman's popularity
to attract a crowd
that would then be there to
hear the rest of the evening.
It worked.
The many in attendance
commented then and later
that they had come to
hear Newman and were,
in some cases reminded of,
and in others, surprised,
by the power of the more
traditional performers.
The festival packed Lafayette's
Blackham Coliseum far past
fire code.
Despite lightning,
thunder, and driving rain,
it turned out to be the
largest mass rally of what came
to be called the Louisiana
French Renaissance Movement.
I knew the fire -- you
can see the crowd there.
I knew the fire marshal
wouldn't shut us
down because his dad was playing
in the third group [laughter].
Southern politics.
Organizers also saw
the opportunity
to use the energy produced
by this initial concert
to fuel a long-term project.
In the momentum of the moment,
the university created
the Center for the Acadian
and Creole Folklore to integrate
this new field of study
into the academic community.
Balfa, who had seen the benefit
of the archives at the Library
of Congress, and at the
Smithsonian Institution,
insisted that we needed a
similar bank of information
on ourselves in Louisiana.
When I pointed out that I didn't
have the financial resources
to produce an archive,
Balfa pointedly asked,
do you have enough
money to buy one tape?
I said, yeah.
He continued, then buy one.
Go out and record an interview
and put that tape on the shelf.
Then record another one
when you can afford it.
And when you put that second
tape next to the first one
on the shelf, you have the
beginnings of an archive.
He was right, as usual.
The beginnings of
the archive were just
that homemade, and it worked.
But, at the same time, counsel
for the development of French
in Louisiana bought
dozens of tapes
and funded early recording
efforts using fieldwork tapes
in French radio programming.
Soon enough, we also
received financial support
from the Rockefeller Foundation
that paid for hundreds of tapes,
which were recorded and
gathered on the shelves
to extend the archive.
We also contacted folklorists
who had worked in Louisiana
in the past, such as Lomax,
Auster, and Rentschler,
who were all happy
to provide copies
of their fieldwork collections.
So, gathered -- finally gathered
in one place for the first time,
the center's archives provided
a sense of the evolution
and development of
Cajun and Creole music
from unaccompanied
ballad tradition
to contemporary dance
band styles.
Fieldwork on oral tradition
and material culture
was added as well.
The field work of students
and colleagues enriched our
understanding of who we were
and how we had come
to be that way.
But the collection was not
meant to be an end in itself.
Instead, it was always intended
to serve as a resource --
a resource for cultural
recycling.
For example, when the
center acquired copies
of Lomax's 1934 field
recordings, it was not only
to repatriate this important
research for archival purposes.
Copies were also
provided to the families
of the original performers
and contemporary musicians were
encouraged to use the collection
as a source for new,
brand-new old songs.
This eventually happened.
Where's my cursor?
Well. I was going
to let you hear it.
>> You can see it on the screen.
>> Billy Jean Ancelet: You
can see it on the screen?
[ Inaudible ]
Okay.
[ Music ]
This is [inaudible] from the
Lomax recordings from '34.
[ Music ]
Oops, sorry.
And this is from 2007.
[ Music ]
Isn't that remarkable?
As Anna Chairetakis,
Alan's daughter,
said when I played
some of this for her,
my God, it worked [laughter].
In the spirit of cultural
recycling, scholars
and staffers associated
with the Center for Acadian
and Creole Folklore have
participated in the production
of festivals and special
performances, television,
radio programs, and offered
classes and workshops
through the university's
French and Francophone studies
and music school programs,
produced books and articles,
communicate new discoveries,
and interpretations
to the local community, as well
as the scholarly community.
There were precious few books
and articles available on Cajun
and Creole culture, and most of
the few that there had been done
by outsiders who often
misunderstood the culture.
I became interested in writing
so that there would be some,
but books and articles do
not reach the larger --
the large audience of Cajuns
and Creoles themselves,
who especially needed
to have access
to information about themselves.
So, center associates
explored other ways
to disseminate our findings.
We joined forces
with record producers
to release archival recordings.
We worked with radio
producers and filmmakers
to produce special programs
and documentaries, collaborated
with educational
institutions to make singers
and storytellers
available for classes
and special lecture series.
This research typically
focuses on contemporary,
as well as historical
aspects of these issues,
considering folklore as a
vital ongoing process rather
than a stagnant product.
Of particular interest is
the process of Creolization,
the unique blending of cultures
that occurred in Louisiana
to produce the folk
architecture, music,
oral tradition, and
cuisine of the region.
Through this range
of activities,
we try to integrate both sides
of folkloristics, the scholarly,
and the public without
getting caught
in the perceived
trap between the two.
Folk festivals have often --
tend to follow a high-energy
model oriented toward large
audiences developed
decades ago at such events
as the National Folk Festival
and the Newport Folk Festival.
This method of presentation
is had positive effects,
not the least of which has been
providing the national level
validation for regional
folk performers
by having them perform on
stages high off the ground
with fancy electronic
amplification before large,
enthusiastic audiences,
often alongside nationally
known performers.
This method also has
certain limitations.
A quieter, more intimate
performance genres are difficult
to program in such
high-energy settings.
In most cultures, ballad singing
is intended for listeners,
that is, without dancing.
It does not usually
happen before thousands,
or even hundreds, of people.
In a large festival
setting, both audience
and performer must be prepared
for this change in format.
Smaller, more intimate so-called
workshops can provide a more
familiar intimate setting, but
even these may not be enough
to set a cultural event in
its best performance context.
By carefully -- drawing on
careful observation of the rules
in nature of cultural
performance
in a natural setting,
folklorists can develop better,
more sensitive, and
more effective
and less abusive methods
of presenting folklore
and folklife in public settings.
Storytelling, for
example, has been one
of the most difficult cultural
features to program effectively
in a festival setting.
Usually storytellers are
tacitly expected to perform
as standup comics, though
many do not possess the skills
for entertaining the masses, nor
are they necessarily interested
in developing those skills.
But settings can be
renegotiated to work better
for performer and
audience as well.
Storytelling is generally, by
nature, an intimate performance
that occurs among a small group
of people who know each other
and share a common
language and references.
Some storytellers can go a long
way toward reaching a festival
or a concert size audience,
which may number in the hundreds
or thousands, but a crowd
that large will strain
even the most outstanding
traditional performer.
During a performance
of what used
to be our university's French
House, Creole storyteller,
Ben Guine, that I met that
night over crawfish etouffee,
renegotiated his audience
in a remarkable way.
A crowd of some 70 people showed
up to hear his extraordinary --
this extraordinary
storyteller perform.
He was pleased with the show
of interest, but, as he began,
I noticed that something
was off.
He was telling well,
but he wasn't taking off
as I had heard him do so often
while listening to his stories
in his living room or
on his front porch.
I realized later
that he was straining
to engage every person
in the room.
He realized this before I did.
I was sitting next to him.
About a third of the way through
the first story he accidentally
bumped my knee during one
of his expansive gestures.
He was trying to hug everybody.
When he noticed I was within
reach, he turned his chair
to face me and proceeded
to tell me the stories.
I was an audience he could
handle, tapping and pushing
and pinching me to make
appropriate points.
I was also an audience
he trusted,
because I understood
the stories.
He knew that.
He hit stride and the rest
of the evening the crowd
watched him tell me stories,
which was much better
for everyone concerned.
When I realize what had
happened, I began experimenting
with new formats for
programming storytelling based
on the concept that Ben had
instinctively put into practice.
This programming strategy, a
sort of theater in the round
where storytellers tell each
other stories while the audience
listens in, became the basis
for the Louisiana Storytellers'
Pavilion that travelled
to festivals throughout
the state in 1984.
By 1974, when Dewey Balfa talked
the Council for the Development
of French in Louisiana into
sponsoring the first Tribute
to Cajun Music concert,
he had already come
to understand enough about
the dynamics of context
and performance from his
own experiences to know
that a Cajun crowd would dance
if it were at all possible,
as they did every Saturday night
in dance halls throughout
south Louisiana.
The intent of the concert
we were producing was
to enable Cajuns to appreciate
the value of their own music
by getting them to listen to it.
So, he strongly suggested
holding the concert in a setting
where dancing would
not be possible.
That evening 12,000
Cajuns wiggled
in their seats [laughter] in
Lafayette's Blackham Coliseum
and listened to the sounds
that they had only heard
before while dancing.
Sometimes festival
organizers develop new ways
of presenting culture
based on own observations
of performance in
its own context.
Sometimes participants can do --
can and do take over
with their own theories
about context and performance.
Over the years, Dewey Balfa
was visited by many folklorists
and invited to many festivals.
He learned from them
what he needed to know
to guide his own efforts to
regenerate interest and respect
for Cajun music in his
native south Louisiana.
This information also turned
Balfa into quite an expert
on folk festival theory,
sometimes to the chagrin
of festival organizers who
have not always thought
out the issues as
well as he had,
and certainly did not
feel them as he did.
There are many examples that
illustrate Dewey's understanding
of culture's process
rather than product.
For years, he tried to convince
festival organizers to allow him
to come with his current
band as he performed
in dance halls every
Saturday night.
He eventually won a partial
victory coming with most
of his dance band, but
he was never allowed
to bring along his steel guitar
to the Smithsonian Festival
of American Folklife.
The argument was that the
steel guitar was too modern,
an inappropriate and
inauthentic addition
to traditional instrumentation.
That's tradition from
their perspective.
Never mind the fact that
Dewey Balfa, long recognized
as a pillar of cultural
preservation in America,
chose to perform weekly with
a steel guitar in his band,
just as dozens of
other Cajun bands did.
In 1978 he finally
confronted festival personnel,
Smithsonian festival personnel
on the issue asking them
pointedly, are you trying
to present Cajun music
as you wish it still
were, or as it really is?
And there was that exact same
deafening silence in the room.
He was allowed that year
to bring along fiddler Dick
Richard, who also played
to his own steel guitar.
Small steps.
In 1985, Dewey delivered a
brilliant extemporaneous address
on the traditional
process from the stage
of the cultural conservation
area of the Washington Festival.
Invited as an outstanding
example of the effort
to conserve America's
traditional culture,
he pointed out halfway
through a 45-minute set
that he had been playing some
traditional songs, songs that he
and his brothers had --
Learned from the
family tradition.
He went on to say that he now
would like to play some songs
that he and his brothers
had composed recently.
He went on to say that he didn't
have to turn around to know
that what he just said had
made some people backstage very
nervous, because he was there to
represent cultural conservation.
But, for him, cultural
conservation did not mean
preserving things.
For him, cultural conservation
meant preserving the life
of the culture, the process.
And, if he was successful,
then the culture was going
to be alive and well
and continue to grow
and evolve it its own terms.
And, if this effort
was successful
in his native Louisiana,
then 50 or so years from now,
some young musicians were going
to need some songs that were 50
or so years old to play.
So, he had made some and
he was going to play one.
He did. He played [inaudible],
and the stage personnel
and audience were
delighted to hear
that his new song sounded
just like the old ones
from his family tradition.
He kept this remarkable
demonstration by pointing out,
he was not one to
leave a point alone,
explaining that they
sounded like the old stuff
because they were coming
from the same tradition
and through the same process and
being performed by the same guy,
so why wouldn't they
sound familiar?
But it was brand new.
Festival organizers should
never be afraid to be surprised.
The people we invite to perform
at festivals sometimes are
undereducated, but never --
I've never found many
to be unintelligent.
In a sense, Dewey's presentation
was much more successful
and authentic than
the authentic like one
that was originally intended
for the cultural
conservation stage that day.
The audience and festival
personnel alike had the
opportunity to learn a
fancy lesson about culture.
After years of performing
in such context,
Dewey learned well how
to operate the machinery.
In this case, he was
aiming his message
in two directions at once.
The immediate message was
aimed at the audience,
but that message and its
reception was obviously meant
to rebound backstage.
At the Liberty Theater we did
a lot of field work on the fly,
sometimes discovering things
that were happening
right on stage.
This is Mitch Reed playing
with Goldman Thibodeau.
He was there to play with
another group and decided
to play with Goldman
and, so, why wouldn't he?
Sometimes the field work was
very close to the presentation,
as in the case of
Horace Trahan's debut.
Some of you may know Horace
Trahan, young Cajun musician.
Helena Putnam, our
Liberty stage manager,
reported hearing a remarkable
young accordion player
and singer at a jam session
at the [inaudible] Acadian
Culture Center next door earlier
that afternoon.
During the Liberty
show that night,
she recognized the young
man sitting in the audience
and pointed him out to me.
I had learned to
trust her instincts.
On a whim, and trusting
her based on years
of shared mutual observations
from our backstage perspective,
I went down into the
audience while a song was on,
was being played, and invited --
asked him if he would
be interested
in performing a song or two.
Yes, sir, he said.
And he came up and we crowbarred
him into the proceedings
that evening, the
performance that evening.
Got him alone sitting
on a chair in the middle
of the stage during
a stolen moment
between scheduled performances.
The crowd spontaneously
gave him a standing ovation.
Not bad for an improvised debut.
He eventually returned
to perform many times
with his own band and others.
Another example, and the
final one I'll give you, is --
has to do with negotiating
performance
and context on the fly.
It comes from an idea I had
when the [speaking foreign
language] was looking
to include a Louisiana
French component
to their event in 1999.
In an attempt to take
into consideration issues
that context-minded folklorists,
such as Frank Proschan
and Charles Cantwell
[assumed spelling],
have addressed calling for
more holistic community-based
programming at folk festivals,
I suggested they invite the
Basile Mardi Gras as a group.
Within this group I suggested
they would have cultural
critical mass that would
include culinary traditions,
the communal gumbo, traditional
music, the ritual song,
and music played for
dancing at the host's houses,
and material culture,
mask and costume making,
as well as the performance
of the ritual itself.
Festival organizers were
eventually convinced
to try this integrated
presentation,
rather than the more
typical approach
that would involve
disparate bearers
of various traditional arts.
So, Basile group went to --
went to Quebec where they
demonstrated the various aspects
of their Mardi Gras.
Visitors could watch the masks
being made then try them on.
They could watch the making
of the gumbo then taste.
They could listen to the
music and dance to it.
Then the Basile group was asked
to put the whole affair together
and demonstrate a run.
The museum organizers
said, well,
what does this --
how does this work?
What does it look like?
Which they were happy to do.
They had demonstrated their
tradition before at Liberty --
at the Liberty Theater,
as well as a few outings
at the Louisiana
Folklife Festival
in several cities
within the state.
But the only real way
to demonstrate a Mardi Gras
run is to run Mardi Gras.
It's the only way that the
carnivalesque dynamic can
be conjured.
So, they cracked up a
performance in the museum.
Now, of course, Mardi
Gras runs are not static.
They move.
The whole point is
to visit and disturb
or tickle what you determine
to be your host community.
So, they headed out the back
door after this performance --
Formed up in the park
behind the museum,
and headed out into the streets.
They didn't have a clear
idea of where they were --
where they were, but they
instinctively improvise the
route and headed down
the sidewalk looking
for the nearest bar [laughter]
doing their ceremonial begging
routines for passersby who had
no clue what this was about.
Luckily, most seemed to
figure out fairly quickly
that this must be some
festive performance associated
with the nearby museum.
I was pressed into
service to hastily explain
to those they encountered
what was going on.
Some understood a
bit and smiled.
Most had little or no idea
how to take the performance
and shied away from the group --
Clutching purses, bags,
and children [laughter].
The museum and festival workers
didn't know this would happen
either, but were reluctant
to restrain what they had,
after all, asked
the group to do.
We were, quite frankly,
all intrigued
to watch the spontaneous
carnivalesque improvisation.
The group processed down the
street with a small entourage
of handlers trying to buffer
the public as much as possible.
They finally made it to a bar,
which should be familiar
territory, and went inside.
They asked for permission to
perform, gathered together,
sang their song, danced
to the music provided
by their accompanying musicians,
and then genuinely begged
for donations from
everybody inside,
including drinks
from the bartender.
Alerted to the situation
and made aware
that this was a spillover
from the nearby [inaudible],
everybody happily cooperated
and the group left happily.
But Mardi Gras is also about
challenging thresholds.
So, once back out of the street,
they escalated the stakes.
They gathered at a
bus stop and waited
for the next bus [laughter].
I was able to convince Captain
Ryder [assumed spelling]
that this might not be a
good idea, since neither
of us knew Quebec
City bus routes
and how far the bus
would take them.
They toyed with the idea
of boarding the bus anyway,
mostly to make me nervous,
then they resumed their
procession along the sidewalk
after a brief standoff
with the bus driver
over who should be
collecting money.
They hit the next bar they saw.
The experience from the first
bar was virtually repeated.
When they left again I was
able to convince the captain
that this was just a
demonstration run after all
and that we could head
back to the museum now.
He agreed and led
his contingent back,
but not without interacting
with everyone they
passed along the way.
When they were safely
back into the museum --
They sang their song
again, danced a bit more,
and then served and
ate the gumbo with all
who were there according
to their tradition.
To the relief of organizers,
no one had been lost or hurt
or too offended, but it was
definitely more Mardi Gras
than they had anticipated
[laughter].
It was probably less than the
participants would happily have
done if given more reign.
The group had extracted
something
like a Mardi Gras feeling out
of this artificial experience
by insisting on going
out on their own terms
and temporarily ignoring
efforts to deter them.
So, where does this leave us?
All sorts of highly
technical studies have derived
from a study -- academic
study of folklore.
And, in my experience, I
found that the possibilities
of focusing, especially
on performance
and contextual theory
in folk arts programming
in the public sector, didn't
need to be conflictual.
Their cultural imperatives
in each performance
of traditional culture,
including setting, time,
constant negotiation between
performers and audience,
to consider -- the consideration
of these complex features
have led to a lot of studies.
Many of these focus
on the capturing
of traditional performance for
contemplation and analysis.
Folklore's espousing contextual
and performance centered
approaches have insisted
on the importance of studying
the very life and nature
of the cultural performance
in its most natural
expression and setting.
Well, that's what Dewey
Balfa was hoping for.
Their discoveries and subsequent
theories can and do serve
to adapt and improve public
presentation of folk arts,
whether within a community-based
cultural presentation,
in a cultural presentation
destined for visitors,
as well as members
of the community,
or in a multicultural
presentation outside
the community.
Conversely, folk --
public folklore --
the public sector folklorists
can and do extract and engage
in performance theory
by observing how
performers adapt themselves
to unfamiliar settings
and unfamiliar settings
to themselves.
These strategies can be
identified to help refine
and improvise future
presentations and settings.
And we've studied
lots of things.
I'm going to hastened
through the next few moments.
We've studied lots of
things, such as the evolution
of house types, from what we
found in France and Acadia,
the Canadian Maritimes, and
how those got improvised
in Louisiana.
The addition of porches, which
shows cultural confluence
of the Acadian and
African [inaudible].
And then, what happens
when that house type is
in everybody's head and you
build a modern house on a slab?
And what happens when
Katrina and Rita blow
through and you get flooded?
Things are constantly being
negotiated in very smart
and meaningful and
ways that make sense.
Food, you know, some --
there are notions of
traditional food ways
that didn't accommodate.
If you get stuck in history,
they don't accommodate
for Cajun eggrolls, crawfish
tamales, microwave rue,
and some other things that
strain the imagination.
[ Laughter ]
All the while, we also enjoy
hamburgers and fried chicken
with iced tea and Dr. Pepper
without feeling we are betraying
our Cajuness [phonetic].
So, I was going to give
you a few examples of --
in the world of Cajun music,
but let me just do one.
Basically, it has to do
with, how do you get --
how did we get from
performing here back in the '30s
to performing here today?
There's a remarkable
difference between the music
that was played here and the
music that's played here.
For one thing, there
was no electricity.
For another thing, it was
essentially for dancers.
It was in the dance
hall, closed off.
Courting is going on.
People are paying attention
to the music only to dance to.
Here, as Dewey pointed
out, what's happening?
Well, people are listening,
people are watching,
people are gathered in a
remarkably different way.
And, so, musicians will
obviously renegotiate what
they're playing.
This is an example of what Ralph
Rentschler recorded the Balfa
brothers playing in 1964, a
song called Parlez-Nous a Boire.
[ Music ]
So, what happens if
you're -- if you're young,
a member of [inaudible],
and you're playing in front
of a crowd that looks more
like that festival crowd?
What will you come up with?
Well, this is what
Chris Stafford
and [inaudible] came up with.
[ Music ]
Now, you know, that probably
upsets the sensibilities
of some people who
think of Cajun music
as historically traditional.
But I'm here to tell you from
my observations in Louisiana,
if you don't do that, then it's
stuck in a preservation hall.
It's dead.
You may not always like it.
Dewey Balfa famously said of
these kinds of matters, he said,
I don't like what they're doing,
but I sure am glad
they're doing it,
which I thought an absolutely
brilliant observation.
Some of the stuff that
people do are designed
to produce arouse from a crowd.
[ Music ]
You can hear --
In the opening of that
version of the Bosco Stomp,
he's letting the crowd have a
chance to cheer and get into it.
People started doing all
sorts of reimagined songs.
Style was shifting within
a traditional repertoire.
People like Steve Riley and the
Mamou Playboys, would do things
like four-part harmonies
on old classics.
[ Music ]
And something about it works.
Rearrange openings for crowd
effect, stringing together two
or more traditional tunes to
produce medleys, rearrange songs
for obvious dramatic effect.
These strategies have influenced
subsequent generations
as is evident in
the arrangements
of many contemporary
Cajun groups.
Eventually, fiddler
David Greely learned
to play a swamp pop saxophone
to accompany accordionist
Steve Riley's forays
into zydeco and swap pop.
People -- things were
changing even faster
than some festival
organizers were expecting.
When Steve Riley, who was
sort of our, you know,
hope for the future, stuck
in the past kind of guy,
imitating the past, heir to
Dewey Balfa, except actually,
he ended up being heir to
do it because he continued
to think about as Dewey did.
When he -- in 1994 he pulled a
big, red, chromatic accordion
out of the bag on
stage at our festival.
The south Louisiana crowd
experienced a moment,
not unlike the one experienced
by the Newport Folk Festival
in '65 when Dylan began
to play Maggie's Farm.
But, as Bruce Jackson has
pointed out, that crowd in '65
in Newport was not mad at Dylan.
They were mad at Peter Yarrow
for trying to get him off.
They were actually loving it.
When festival producers
heard the new licks,
there was some consternation
and concern
that the traditional Cajun
music's fair-haired band was
sliding toward the
progressive side.
What was undeniable was,
that the crowd loved it.
A remarkable exchange of e-mails
I had with Greely and Ben,
manager and bassist Peter
Schwartz, demonstrated
that band members were
keenly aware of these issues,
as well as the effects
of changing context,
audience expectations
at home and on the road,
and the tensions between
artistic and cultural integrity.
So --
What happens?
It continues, and
people continue
to experiment producing new
songs, some of them that take
on the audience, issues
of cultural and natural
and linguistic erosion.
Listen to the first words.
[ Music ]
And this is Steve Riley and the
Mamou Playboys' typical opening
song at outdoor concerts.
It's called Danser
san comprendre,
Dancing Without Understanding.
[ Music ]
Why am I sing --
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
In a language you
don't understand?
Why am I singing in a
language you don't understand?
And he goes on to say, you know,
say [speaking foreign language].
It's not enough to dance
without understanding.
You've got to fully engage.
I mean, they were taking
on the crowd saying,
you know, yeah, that's fine.
You all are dancing
and pretending
to love this stuff,
but it takes more.
You've got engage more.
And there were other
things that, you know,
toyed with what was going on.
[ Music ]
Why not? Some, including poet,
[inaudible] explored
possibilities,
including Cajun hip-hop
and neo-metal.
Others, Ann Savoy, Jane Vadrene
[assumed spelling], Megan Brown,
Kelli Jones, Savoy elected to
explore in other directions.
[ Music ]
That's an old song from
-- there I am again.
the Lomax collection.
And, obviously, recycled and
rethought and regenerated.
But they all continue to
produce music that is playful
and thoughtful and challenging,
as we expect young music to be.
At the same time, it's as
respectful and grounded
as I hope it would be.
Young Cajun music
is a perfect example
of what Dewey Balfa meant
when he said he wanted
to preserve not the music
itself, but the process
that produces the music, so
that musicians will continue
to innovate and improvise new
forms that both surprise us
and reassure us at
the same time.
And this brings us
back to Henry Glassie.
This an obviously ongoing
process, undoubtedly influenced
by the past, but
not trapped in it.
In the spirit of Glassie's
definition of tradition,
as quote, the creation of
the future out of the past.
Dewey Balfa also said, a culture
is preserved one generation
at a time.
Cajun and Creole cultures have
endured in their own terms
into the present
generation, what happens
in the next will continue
to decide their futures.
They have remarkable
filtering systems.
Once again, it is
critically important
to consider the context,
especially those
who consume all this
cultural activity.
How long will young Cajun and
Creole bands play what they play
without some sort of
crowd to play for?
Turning the fieldwork gaze
toward the crowds exposes a
simple truth, what works
doggedly it endures,
and what doesn't work
fades mercifully away.
Yet Dewey, who learned
about cultural activism
from the intellectual
descendants of Alan Lomax
and Charles Seeger, realize
that we should not leave
such things entirely to the
laws of natural selection,
and urge that we water the roots
so that the tree might
have a chance to live.
Despite the admittedly activist
perspective that we share,
we both know you can't force the
passage of tradition on anyone.
What I have tried to do is
to observe it, understand it
as well as I can, and
present the results
of that understanding in
as many ways as I can --
I can think of, including
academic reporting,
media presentation,
public presentation.
In that public presentation I
have tried to make it attractive
and available, and then step
back and watch what happens,
and then try to understand that.
And folklore and fieldwork
continue to be the best ways
to understand this process that
evolves at the speed of life.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Sorry. Sorry, that
was a little long.
But we have maybe a
little time for questions?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, sure.
Uh-huh?
[ Inaudible ]
[ Laughter ]
We don't pass people along.
[ Inaudible ]
But, yeah, and you know,
sometimes, you know,
musicians who are aware of this
have challenged the fourth wall.
I remember back in
1980 something,
Rockin Dopsie had
a 50-foot cord.
We were always wondering, why
does he have a 50-foot cord?
And in the first song he stepped
back and took off and jumped
into the crowd and played.
It was like -- and this was
like before mosh pits, right?
So, I think the -- to me, the
most important thing to take,
one of the most important
things to take out of --
out of all of this is,
that it's a mistake
to confuse history
and tradition.
You know, history is what
happened in the past,
and tradition is what came
from it, but is still going on,
and it's still happening
and it's producing what
we're experiencing today.
And, in that regard, it has --
it has a quality of the
present and even the future.
And sometimes it surprises
us in ways that we kind
of wish we weren't surprised,
but too bad, you know.
We're not cultural
policeman, and we shouldn't be.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
Well, in the words of
Mark Savoir, [inaudible],
and a musician from south
Louisiana, one begins with a C
and the other begins
with a Z [laughter].
There are some tendencies,
and, you know,
you could probably tease
them out toward the edges,
but there's so much
common ground in the middle
that I don't know why -- I'm
not sure it's all that useful.
Zydeco is proudly the product
of the Creole community,
the African Creole
community of Louisiana,
and Cajun music is the product
of the French Acadian community,
but they owe so much to each
other, and they've inter --
they've interlaced in so many
ways and influenced each other
in so many ways that -- and that
is what's wonderful about it.
It would be kind of like -- it
would be kind of like trying
to analyze a gumbo [laughter].
You know, yeah, there's flour
and oil and onions and chicken
and garlic, but it's better
just to eat the gumbo.
[ Inaudible ]
Of what?
Hippy Ti Yo.
For a long time people --
well, there are a lot of words
like this, like zydeco
itself, right?
People thought, well, that's
the [inaudible] in French.
Except the problem is,
that the way it's used,
[speaking foreign
language], what, are you going
to string bean all night?
No. So, it's not a
noun, it's the verb.
And, you know, without going
into a long explanation,
if you look to France
[inaudible].
Where's the other place
this stuff came from?
West Africa.
And there, that term, seems to
be closely associated to dancing
and courtship rituals.
[ Inaudible ]
A lot of people thought it was
[inaudible] the term tie yo,
which is the Cajun French
word for a hound dog.
They thought it was about
two [inaudible] hound dogs,
[speaking foreign
language], they stole my sled,
except that doesn't make
a lot of sense either.
Well, how would dogs be stealing
a sled, and why would they?
Well, it turns out that
hippy ti yo, the whole term,
and don't carve out
the ti yo part,
hippy ti yo is what Cajuns
heard cowboys from Texas yelling
when they were herding cattle,
as in yippi yi yo ca
yea gallop [inaudible].
That makes a lot more sense,
those bums from Texas
were stealing our sled
[inaudible] dogs.
But sometimes when you
point out these things
that you're discovering through,
you know, linguistic analysis,
it makes the people nervous.
No, no, I want my beans,
I want my dogs [laughter].
Sometimes knowledge is
inconvenient [laughter].
>> [Inaudible] questions?
>> Billy Jean Ancelet: Yeah,
yeah, sure, as many as you like.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
I have had a blast.
What's that?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah?
Yeah.
>> Do you know why?
>> Billy Jean Ancelet:
Well, [inaudible].
There are different
places to play.
That erosion of the traditional,
historical dance hall began
when restaurants started
programming [inaudible] along
with, you know, [inaudible]
and started making spaces
in their restaurants.
So, and more restaurants
were regularly [inaudible].
So, dance halls started
[inaudible].
But, you know, nobody --
there aren't any house
dances anymore either.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, yeah?
And sometimes that stuff is
surprising, which is good.
I often say that
when the process
that I was just describing is
really in stride and hitting
on all eight cylinders, it's
working well, it produces things
that both surprise us and
reassure us in the same moment.
We say, wow, I didn't
see that coming,
but I see where it came from.
>> One more question.
>> Billy Jean Ancelet: Okay.
[ Inaudible ]
[ Laughter ]
I could tell you, but --
no, there are people who --
[ Inaudible ]
And by the way, we
just last year,
just this past year we revisited
something that we had done
in the '80s, and that
is we did an exhibition,
a museum exhibition
of traditional instruments
made in south Louisiana.
[ Inaudible ]
Steel guitars, drums, percussion
bands, violins, [inaudible].
So, if you want -- if you want
to play that badly [inaudible].
>> We probably should
wrap this up.
But I wanted to thank
Professor Ancelet
for coming and for [inaudible].
[ Applause ]